hablemos un poco del modelo del mosaico
fluido de la membrana celular y primero
porque se llama modelo del mosaico
fluido bueno la respuesta es la
siguiente si vemos la membrana de una
célula déjame dibujar te por aquí una
célula
imagínate que por aquí ésta es tu
celular y bueno por aquí tienes un poco
de volumen y la membrana de tu célula es
lo que separa el interior de las células
de cualquier cosa afuera de ella lo que
estaremos viendo es un corte transversal
de esta superficie de la superficie de
nuestra membrana celular entonces si
hacemos un pequeño acercamiento de esta
parte de aquí lo que vamos a ver es
justo esto que tenemos aquí una bicapa
fosfolípidos voy a decir que aquí tengo
el interior de mi celular el inte
orden celular y porque el exterior
pero seguro cuando oyes que la membrana
es una bicapa fosfolípidos una pregunta
que se te viene a la mente luego luego
es bueno y que es fosfolípido y esa es
una buena pregunta porque cuando
entiendas lo que es un fosfolípido
tendrá sentido el por qué se forma una
bicapa como esta que tenemos aquí y por
qué es la base de muchas membranas en
los sistemas biológicos entonces esto
que vemos aquí esto de aquí es la
representación de un fosfolípidos así
que déjame ponerle su nombre esto de
aquí es un fosfolípido fos
y como su nombre lo indica es un lípido
con un grupo de fosfato y en general la
palabra lípido implica que no se
disuelve en agua de hecho tenemos todo
un vídeo acerca de los lípidos y justo
esto aplica para los fosfolípidos aquí
vemos estas cadenas de carbonos que
tengo justo por aquí
una de ellas y aquí tengo la otra de
ellas que provienen de los ácidos grasos
y justo estas colas que tenemos aquí no
tienen una polaridad obvia no tienen una
carga obvia y eso es bueno porque
sabemos que el agua es una molécula
polar y por eso se pueden formar los
puentes de hidrógeno y atraerse a sí
misma pero estas colas no tienen esta
característica entonces no van a ser
atraídas por el agua y el agua no será
atraída por ellas por lo tanto estas
cosas son hidrofóbicas déjenme ponerlo
aquí
hidrofóbicas
pero
ubicadas entonces los fuegos felipe 2
tienen estas cadenas hidrofóbicas que
estoy poniendo justo aquí y de hecho
esta es la parte líquida de los
fosfolípidos y luego también tenemos
esta parte de aquí que es nuestra cabeza
de fosfato y aquí claramente puedes ver
en esta cabeza de fosfato que tiene
carga tiene una ligera carga pero esta
nos va a ayudar a atraer moléculas que
tengan también carga las moléculas con
carga les va a ir bien con las
sustancias polares como el agua porque
se pueden disolver bastante bien por lo
tanto esta parte de aquí esta cabeza que
tengo aquí es hidrofílico déjame ponerlo
esta cabeza que tengo aquí es
pero cilic a fin rica
y justo las moléculas que tienen una
parte hidrofílica y una parte
hidrofóbica tienen un nombre bastante
especial se les conoce con el nombre de
antipáticas y es un nombre que a mí me
cuesta un poco de trabajo pronunciar
pero bueno
regresando al tema por lo tanto el
fosfolípidos es una molécula annan
simpática lo que significa que tiene
tanto un extremo hidrofílico que es
atraído por el agua como un extremo
hidrofóbico que no es atraído por el
agua y ojalá esto te empiece a explicar
el por qué se organizan de esta manera
como puedes imaginarte las cabezas
hidrofílicas querrán estar donde está el
agua que es justo afuera de la célula en
el exterior o adentro del celular en el
interior mientras que las colas como son
hidrofóbicas van a huir del agua o el
agua va a huir de ellas y por lo tanto
se pondrán frente
y quedarán en el interior de la membrana
pero lo más emocionante de todo esto es
que una estructura como ésta una
molécula antipática permite que se
formen bicapa lipídicas y esto es
fascinante si pudiéramos viajar al
pasado incluso antes de que existían las
células como estructuras básicas de la
vida en nuestro planeta es probable que
encontráramos algo así fosfolípidos que
espontáneamente formarán déjame ponerlo
algo así el fosfolípidos que
espontáneamente formarán algo así como
estas esferas de bicapa fosfolípidos
déjame ponerlo así un poco más rápido
aquí voy a tener una estructura más o
menos así y lo que quiero que veas es
que se formarían una bicapa fósforo
lipídica entonces en el centro también
tendríamos algo más o menos así y ahora
con otro color
voy a dibujar todas las colas que
tendríamos aquí todas las colas de
lípidos que tendríamos aquí creo que más
o menos entiende mi idea por aquí
también voy a tener todas las demás
colas si tenemos bueno alaska
de fosfolípidos todas estas cosas
provienen de ambas capas y es que esto
está padrísimo porque observa que en
este momento al formarse espontáneamente
esto se entiende como una proto celular
información claro y bueno para tener
vida verdadera
necesitamos contener algún tipo de
información que se pueda heredar y
también necesita tener un tipo de
metabolismo y claro todo esto es lo que
te indica la definición de vida pero al
menos esta estructura básica que estoy
poniendo justo aquí esta estructura que
estoy dibujando o intentando dibujar
justo aquí pudo haber sido o pudo haber
formado un estado de pre vida y gracias
a estas moléculas las moléculas
antipáticas como los fosfolípidos nos
dan esa estructura básica de la membrana
celular
ya logramos formar esta capa
fosfolípidos pero que son todas estas
otras cosas que tengo justo por aquí y
bueno
todas estas otras cosas son proteínas
esta de aquí es una proteína extra que
es una proteína estar acá también es una
proteína y sólo dibuje unas masas para
indicar la variedad de proteínas que
tenemos por aquí pero lo más importante
que hay que ver es que si pensamos en
las células
hay que saber que también tienen toda
esta variedad de proteínas es decir que
hay toda esta complejidad incrustada
justo aquí en nuestra membrana celular
si está fuera por ejemplo nuestra célula
y me estoy fijando aquí en su membrana
bueno pues tendríamos varias proteínas
incrustadas en esta membrana es decir
que no es solamente una mica pafos foley
vírica uniforme hay muchas cosas en ella
si vemos un corte de esta sección vamos
a ver algo así muchas proteínas
incrustadas en ella como lo muestra este
e incluso podemos decir que hay un
mosaico de cosas en ella y es que
recuerda un mosaico es una imagen hecha
de un puñado distintos de componentes de
distintos colores como justo aquí aquí
puedes ver la membrana distintos
componentes que son estos distintos
tipos de proteínas tenemos este tipo de
proteínas aquí que atraviesa la membrana
esto también a través de la membrana y
de hecho a estas proteínas se les conoce
con el nombre de proteínas transmembrana
les son un tipo especial de proteínas
integrales y también tenemos proteínas
integrales como ésta que sólo pueden
interactuar con una parte de la pick-up
aquí tengo otra y bueno por acá tengo
más mientras que éstas la pueden
atravesar esta no y bueno aquí este de
ver de aquí este es un blue con lípido
déjame notar la luz
este se coloca en la membrana porque
tiene este extremo lipídico que tengo
aquí este que tengo aquí y entonces como
éstos hidrofóbico bueno pues se va a
llevar bastante bien con todas estas
cosas hidrofóbicas y en su otro extremo
tenemos una cadena de azúcares esta
parte es hidrofílico entonces se
colocarán afuera de la célula y estas
cadenas de azúcares que tenemos aquí son
clave para el reconocimiento célula a
célula nuestro sistema inmune las
utiliza para diferenciar las células que
son de nuestro cuerpo de las que no lo
son éstas nos permiten reconocer los
agentes de los que el cuerpo se requiere
proteger porque es posible que no se
enfermen y además cuando las personas
hablan del tipo sanguíneo hablan de
grupos lípidos glucose lípidos
específicos que tenemos claro están y
éstos no son los únicos grupos lípidos
también hay algunos como estos o bueno
algunos como éste y hay de distintos
tipos y esto es bastante fascinante como
cosas como estas como cadenas de
azúcares pues
llevar a un comportamiento tan complejo
y para nosotros un comportamiento tan
útil pero las células no solamente
tienen cadenas de azúcares en lípidos
también hay cadenas azúcares en
proteínas como esta de aquí este de aquí
es una lipoproteína déjame ponerlo si
lee
cómo
pro de la y
y bueno si pones todo esto junto se
forma un mosaico y no solamente eso aún
no ha acabado también tenemos cosas como
este de aquí que es colesterol el cual
también está incrustado en esta membrana
pero el colesterol es un lípido que se
acomoda en la parte hidrofóbica de la
membrana y de hecho el colesterol
influye en la fluidez de la membrana
garantiza que no sea muy flexible pero
tampoco muy rígida entonces esto de aquí
es el colesterol y bueno es justo por
eso que tenemos un mosaico y aquí dice
el modelo del mosaico fluido ya tenemos
un modelo mosaico pero seguramente te
vas a preguntar de dónde viene la parte
fluido y justo acabo de hablar de la
importancia del colesterol recuerdas el
cual garantiza que la membrana tenga la
fluidez adecuada ya que la membrana no
es una estructura rígida
imagínate que esta proteína de aquí
saliera en algún momento no se la vamos
a quitar la vamos a mover del lugar
entonces de alguna manera los
fosfolípidos espontáneamente se
reacomodarían para llenar el hueco de
hecho puedes imaginarte todas estas
cosas moviéndose por ahí ya que esta
membrana tiene la consistencia de una
aceite o de un aderezo o algo así
entonces no tiene una textura curiosa
como lo tiene la membrana plástica de un
globo de hecho es flexible es un fluido
estas cosas se pueden mover pero aunque
es fluida es muy buena para separar dos
ambientes el ambiente interior de la
célula del ambiente exterior que la
rodea y por eso se llama modelo del
mosaico fluido